first up she is the subject of the
seven part netflix series it was
fantastic pretended to city and in april
2022 she'll be performing at the broad
stage here in santa monica fran
lieberwicz is with us
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so great to see you it's been nice
to see anyone
anyone been been too long how was your
pandemic
there were certain things i liked about
it i know you're not allowed i thought
maybe you would because you like staying
home reading all day yeah well
yeah but not all night right
so that was good i mean many things that
i always wished for
you know i got in a certain way like i
wanted the you know
tourists out of times square but then
when i saw it at the highly epidemic
when i was walking around
i thought yes but not this way right
like you know
could is wasn't there some way they
could leave without you know half a
million people dying
i didn't mean that i don't mean die i
mean just don't come
you know uh i always they'll be back
because new york will be back i know
oh there's no yeah right i mean there's
no questions you know it's not
surprising to me but
um they're trying you know they're
people in new york not me
the people who own stuff like you know
theaters and buildings and
um how can we make it like it was as if
it was perfect
you know like how about there were
things wrong with before
you know whenever there's a disaster no
one can think past a disaster
you know well that's not true because
when a lot of people are not going to go
back to
going to an office certainly not like
five days a week yeah well luckily i
never did that did you
yes yes i came and i miss it but i could
i will compromise with the staff who
wants to to stay home
alternatively they don't never want to
see this building again
i like a i i like a writer's meeting
with writers in it
well in the same [ __ ] room i do
i like to see the fear on their faces
the show is always
it's just
but so how was the flight i'm very
curious if you are as
bothered by the inconsistencies as i am
in how we handled this you know like the
fact that planes were always okay
but i couldn't do a concert really a
plane is safer
than an outdoor venue to do a concert or
even an indoor venue
how about dining you know you put the
mask on
when you walk in but when you're sitting
the virus would never
think of jumping in you when you're
it's please he's with people he's eating
does this bother you well i mean there's
there
there seems to be a lack of
understanding of what air is
i mean in other words in new york they
put air is yeah
yeah other places i'm sure they put
these plastic dividers between tables
and you know it's not a pleasant feeling
you know you feel like you know
i didn't kill anyone do i have to be
behind this plastic like i said
right you feel like eichmann at the end
you know what is this for well this is
to keep the air from going from
table to table i said really can i smoke
right he said no of course you can't
smoke i said if this worked i could
smoke
i said because they would stop the smoke
right here
air doesn't do that air goes up it goes
down
i mean right not a meteorologist but i
know air doesn't just go this way
you know i remember right the same thing
with planes took you to that met game
you did and just to smoke you had to
walk like around the entire stadium
no i had to walk and first of all uh
that's the only time i've been to
i know it's not called um shea stadium
anymore whatever it's called
city field yes um it is
that's the only time i've been there i
haven't been back uh in the distance
no one has been back by the way i'm
sorry no one has been back
we had we didn't really was that the
last baseball games no but we had no
fans last year almost drove me into
bankruptcy anyway go on with your story
i went but i was not a fan so uh
to walk to the place you had to smoke
yeah right
i felt i was getting more exercise than
the baseball player
i felt that when i finally got there and
lit up
i should have gotten like a run or
whatever you call it right so yes i do
i remember vividly doing that okay so i
must tell you
your show on netflix was so [ __ ]
fantastic
thank you so hysterically funny and you
you and marty together i mean but you
know i say we made it together you're
the show
i did three nights with you as you
recall in silicon valley silicon valley
we did
you are the fastest gun in the west even
the comedians
would would give that to you really
whoever is on stage with you
is going to be the straight man and i'm
pretty [ __ ] funny
yeah but even and you're pretty straight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and i see now can i make a prediction
for your
this decade you just turned 70 i did
okay
your 70s you're going to be the hottest
ticket on campus
well i i i truthfully i already have
like a billion dates for 20 20. i know
i'm saying it's about time
right i guess you deserve it you're the
funniest one out there and and the kids
are catching up no it's gonna be great
and you know you always are complaining
about being impact unions you will not
be able to lean on that anymore you're
going to be flush
and of course because this is the year
that if you make a lot of money they're
going to take it all in taxes when i saw
that i've always been advocating for
this
and i thought not this year no please
don't do it this year
you